Sarah leidet unter den Folgen einer Nasen-OP.
– Zum einen hat er mir zu viel Haut entfernt,
besonders von der Nasenspitze.
Das heißt meine Nase ist
hier taub.
Auch Christina hat sich auf die 5-Sterne Bewertungen
dieses Chirurgen verlassen.
Dabei hat der Arzt im Internet viele gute
Bewertungen.
Wie kann das sein?
Wir recherchieren – und finden Firmen, die
ihr Geld mit gekauften Bewertungen verdienen,
wie die Bewertungsplattform Goldstar Marketing.
An einem geheimen Ort treffen wir einen Mitarbeiter.
Er spielt uns interne Dokumente zu.
Unser Arzt ist kein Einzelfall, viele Ärzte
pimpen ihr Profil mit top-Bewertungen:
–Wir haben wirklich massig viele Ärzte
und Zahnärzte als Kunden.
Wir sind auf der Spur eines internationalen
Netzwerks, das sich geschickt der Justiz entzieht.
Und Sie bleiben draußen.
Und damit Basta Aus!
Sarah hat ein Problem mit ihrer Nase.
Und fängt an zu suchen:
Das Ärzte-Portal Jameda empfiehlt ihr einen
Arzt - mit besten Bewertungen.
–Die positiven Bewertungen haben bei mir
ein gutes Gefühl ausgelöst, dass ich dort
bestimmt gut aufgehoben sein werde und später
die Nase haben werde, die ich mir auch schon
immer gewünscht habe.
–Es gibt ein paar Studien, die besagen,
dass ungefähr 80 Prozent der Menschen, die
nach solchen Bewertungen lesen, diese auch
für wahr halten.
Noch Monate nach der Operation hat Sarah Probleme.
Dicke Narben.
Ihre Nase fühlt sich taub an.
Sarah macht dem plastischen Chirurgen schwere
Vorwürfe.
–Zum einen hat er mir zu viel Haut entfernt,
besonders von der Nasenspitze.
Wenn ich morgens aufstehe,
ist meine Nase immer sehr angeschwollen.
Man kennt das ja, wenn man
Schnupfen hat, weiß man erst zu schätzen,
wie es ist durch die Nase zu atmen.
Sarah ist nicht die Einzige: Christina war
beim selben Arzt für eine Brust-Op.
Ihr mussten die Brüste schließlich ganz
entfernt werden.
Und das war nicht das Einzige.
–Dieser Stich vom Skalpell, das Ansetzten,
wo man einfach merkt, du wirst gerade aufgeschnitten,
realisierst es aber doch irgendwie nicht ganz,
weil der Schmerz so intensiv ist, dass du
einfach nur denkst, hoffentlich hat er es
jetzt. Und ich habs ihm gesagt, ​a​llerdings
hat er gemeint, ich könnte keine Schmerzen
haben, ich würde simulieren und für mich
war das wie so ein Schlag ins Gesicht, wenn
der Arzt selber da steht und im Endeffekt
dir sagt, dass du gerade in dem Moment einfach
Mist erzählst.
Und ich aber da liege und das spüre und er
sagt, dass kann nicht sein.
Sarah und Christina sind nicht alleine mit
ihrer Erfahrung: Dutzende Patient:Innen haben
den plastischen Chirurgen angezeigt.
Viele haben Schmerzen, leiden psychisch, sind
entstellt.
Und trotzdem hat genau dieser Arzt Rezensionen
vom Feinsten.
Kann das stimmen?
Oder werden Bewertungen manipuliert, vielleicht
sogar gekauft?
Das wollen wir wissen - und googlen erstmal:
Erste Überraschung: Es gibt viele Treffer.
Die Anbieter haben Namen wie Fivestar Marketing,
“Bewertungen Kaufen” oder Goldstar-Marketing.
“Bewertungen sind die wichtigste Währung
im Internet.”
Bei Goldstar Marketing im Angebot: Bewertungen
für Google, Amazon und Sonstige Plattformen
- wie Jameda.
Firmen wie Goldstar sind schwer zu greifen.
Alles läuft virtuell ab.
Unsere Anfragen bleiben unbeantwortet.
Dann meldet sich doch jemand, aber nicht offiziell.
Ein Goldstar-Mitarbeiter lädt uns zu einem
Treffen ein - an einem geheimen Ort.
Denn er will auspacken über millionenfache
Lügen im Internet und das große Geschäft.
– Es ist mittlerweile fast alles gefälscht
und gefakt.
Man kann da leider keinen Wert drauf geben,
seien es Produktrezensionen, sei es eine Meinung
über einen Arzt, über eine Fahrschule, über
Anwälte.
Autohändler sind auch sehr große Kunden.
Sie kaufen für mobile.de oder Autoscout.
- Und wie läuft die Akquise?
Wir rufen Firmen an und erklären ihnen dann,
wir sind von der Firma Goldstar Marketing.
Wir machen Bewertungskampagnen und übernehmen
die Arbeit ihrer zufriedenen Kunden.
– Und was versprechen Sie denen?
– Alles.
– Mehr Kunden natürlich.
– Und vor allem mehr Umsatz.
Für seine Behauptungen hat der Informant
handfeste Beweise.
Er gibt uns hochbrisante Unterlagen aus dem
Innenleben von Goldstar Marketing: Rechnungen,
Zahlungsbelege, Email-Verkehr.
Tausende Dokumente, die belegen: Positive
Bewertungen bei Google, Amazon und anderen
Portalen werden zu hunderten, zu tausenden
gekauft.
Rechtsanwälte, Ärzte, Handwerker - sogar
Stadtwerke machen mit.
Und wir stoßen auf einen alten Bekannten,
den plastischen Chirurgen.
Er bestellte 100 Google-Bewertungen für 879,XX
Euro.
Wir wollen den Arzt mit unserer Recherche
persönlich konfrontieren, denn auf unsere
schriftlichen Fragen hat er nicht reagiert.
Wir suchen ihn in seiner Praxis auf, doch
die ist verschlossen.
Wir erfahren: Die Behörden haben ihm die
Approbation entzogen.
Wir gehen zu seiner Privatadresse und drehen
mit versteckter Kamera:
– Also ich habe nie irgendwelche Bewertungen
gekauft.
Meine Bewertungen sind alle echt.
– Aber ich habe hier eine Bestellung über
Google-Bewertungen.
Die müsste ja von Ihnen sein?
– Es kann sein, dass meine Internetbetreuer,
zum Zeitpunkt als die Hetze gegen mich losging,
gesagt haben, ok, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken,
dass wir da ein bisschen Luft reinkriegen.
Den Vorwurf, er habe Operationen verpfuscht,
weist der Arzt vehement zurück.
Unser Goldstar-Informant erinnert sich an
den plastischen Chirurgen.
– Er hat sehr viele Bewertung gekauft für
seine Praxis.
Den genauen Umfang weiß ich nicht.
Nur 5- Sterne-Bewertungen, so dass er natürlich
als super Arzt hingestellt wird.
Aber er ist nicht der einzige.
Wir haben wirklich massig viele Ärzte und
Zahnärzte als Kunden.
Positive Bewertungen bei Google, Amazon und
auf anderen Portalen werden zu tausenden gekauft.
Das belegen die Dokumente unseres Whistleblowers.
Wir wollen den Chef des Bewertungsportals
Goldstar Marketing damit konfrontieren, denn:
Gekaufte Bewertungen posten, das ist nicht
strafbar.
Allerdings könnte ein Verstoß gegen die
Regeln des fairen Wettbewerbs vorliegen.
Nach langer Suche finden wir den Chef Norbert
Weber vor seiner Villa in Grunewald:
– Wir sind vom ZDF und hatten ihnen Fragen
geschickt?
Wir wollen hier keine Aufnahmen haben.
– Haben Sie unsere Fragen bekommen?
– Ja, haben wir, aber wir antworten da nicht
drauf.
Und Sie bleiben draußen.
Und damit Basta Aus!
Norbert Weber schweigt über sein Geschäftsmodell.
Unser Informant, der Goldstar-Mitarbeiter,
hat Antworten​.
– Das Geschäft mit den Bewertungen, ist das
lukrativ?
– Ich würde schätzen, er verdient damit
zwischen 3 und 5 Millionen Euro im Jahr.
Damit wird er definitiv reich.
Christina schreibt eine negative Bewertung.
Von Jameda wurde sie nie veröffentlicht.
Später bemerkte sie - auch andere äußerten
Kritik:
Aber diese Bewertungen wurden schnell wieder
gelöscht.
Jameda sagt: Es fehlten die Beweise.
Nach unseren Recherchen gibt es viele Ärzte,
die Jameda-Bewertungen kaufen.
Das Unternehmen meint dazu:
– Wenn jetzt zwei oder drei schlechte Bewertungen
gelesen hätte, hätte wenigstens einen kleinen
Zweifel gehabt an dem Ganzen und hätte mir
vielleicht fünf Mal überlegt, ob ich da
hingehe oder mir vielleicht nochmal ne Zweitmeinung
eingeholt.
Da ich aber eine 1,0-Bewertung gelesen habe,
war ich der Meinung der Arzt ist tippitoppi
und an den kann ich gehen und dem kann ich
blind vertrauen.
Der Fall des plastischen Chirurgen beschäftigt
jetzt auch die Justiz.
Gegen den Arzt wird wegen mehrfacher schwerer
Körperverletzung ermittelt.
Der Arzt hingegen klagt gegen den Entzug seiner
Approbation - in diesem Prozess.
Und er streitet alle Vorwürfe ab.
Doch zahlreiche Patient:innen wollen Schmerzensgeld.
Falsche Bewertungen kann man vielleicht noch
löschen.
Eine verpfuschte Nase nicht.
Worauf achtest du, wenn du einen Arzt suchst?
Schreib es uns in die Kommentare!